For our likePhoto code,
which let's the user comments on,
and like a photo or picture online,
you may have noticed that our function only works when we know and can
input the number of currentLikes a photo has as our first argument.
Like if we know a photo has 10 currentLikes,
we can do a function call to likePhoto with the value 10 passed in as our first argument,
and this will correspond to our currentLikes parameter.
Our second argument is a comment string,
and our third is a boolean value,
that corresponds to our boolean like parameter.
If this argument is true,
we'll increase the number of currentLikes by one.
So in this case, because our boolean like will be set to true,
we'll increase our currentLikes from 10 to 11.
In this function call, we'll print out the comment,
great photo, as well as the increased number of likes, 11.
But how do we know that a photo had 10 likes to begin with?
Let's think about how to automatically keep track of the number of
likes a photo has when a person first puts a photo up.
When a picture is first posted,
it starts out with zero likes and also no comments.
Then if a few people see it and like or comment,
we can try to use our function likePhoto to handle this.
The first function call might be from someone who likes our photo.
So we start off with these three arguments.
In int value of zero,
which corresponds to our currentLikes parameter since there are no likes yet,
a comment string that just says,
"Nice color," and a boolean value of true for a boolean like parameter.
Since our boolean like parameter will be set to this argument value of true,
this should add to the currentLikes that this photo has.
In this function call,
we'll print out the comment,
Nice color, and the number of likes which is increased to one.
Then say another person comes along and
likes the photo again using another function call.
This time we know that after our first function call,
our currentLikes should have increased from zero to one.
So to reflect this,
we want our second function call to have one as its first argument.
And here are argument values are one for the currentLikes,
a string that just says, "I like this."
And a boolean value, true,
which means that the photo has been liked a second time.
In this second function call,
we'll print out our comment and the current number of likes,
which now have increased to two.
But what if this first person changes their mind about liking the photo?
They still comment, but their boolean like argument will be false.
So the first function call will be the same,
but this time the boolean argument for liking a photo will be set to false.
This means that our currentLikes won't increase,
so our value for currentLikes which we've input is zero should stay as zero.
It shouldn't increase to one.
In this call, we'll print out the same comment,
but this time the number of likes will be zero.
And to reflect this change down the line in our second function call,
we'll have to change the value of our currentLikes
argument from one to zero in this call.
Now these function calls are updated and correct.
Our first call will leave a comment but doesn't increase the likes,
and our second should increase the likes by one.
Right now we're looking at this print output
and directly writing in the correct number of currentLikes,
zero or one in our second function call.
But what if we wanted our program to keep track of the currentLikes for us?
This would be easier if we could access and keep
track of the number of currentLikes automatically,
but right now that information is only in our likePhoto function definition.
The current number of likes a photo has is kept track
of in the variable inside of our likePhoto function definition code.
That's where we change its value if someone likes a photo and where we print it out.
But we can't reach this value outside of this definition,
so we can't use it in separate programs,
like when we actually call
the function likePhoto and want to use the value to keep track of the currentLikes.
To access and use the value of currentLikes outside of our function definition,
we want to change the definition so that
instead of just calculating the likes and printing them,
it returns the likes as output data, as a return value.
This is sort of like how we could input outside information into
a function call by including parameters in our function definition.
But instead of input,
this time we're producing output that can be accessed outside this definition.
This will become clearer when we see an example.
So let's see the steps we need to take to return values like this.